make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
okay so we are back with part three of
our marvel cosmic hierarchy
series and again i have no idea how you
guys are responding to the other two
i hope it's positive i hope i hope it's
it's interesting again this is all just
kind of my interpretation of this stuff
so by no
standard of measurement is this like an
absolute rule but uh
in this one with our with our next
installment here right with our uh
really the first person we're picking up
on this list which we have at the number
10 spot is the marquee of death
and i know that this is going to be one
where people kind of see this a little
controversial but one of the things we
talked about in the last
hierarchy video we did is that by the
time we finished the beyonders from that
point going forward
it wasn't necessarily a display of the
power that people had because pretty
much everybody on this list has what are
in effect
similar powers it's really the the way
in which they use their powers and the
expediency by which they were able to do
the things they did the marquee of death
was
wildly wildly powerful right if you guys
remember the video that we did beyond
mega level the marquee of death it's one
of the most popular videos we've done on
the channel this guy was wiping out
universes with a wave of his hand
right this guy was hugely powerful the
reason why i don't have the marquee of
death higher up on this video
is because the way he was defeated that
he was ultimately destroyed by doctor
doom despite doctor doom not having the
same level of power
as the marquee of death now i won't
spoil all that make sure you guys go
check that video out it's really cool
but the marquee of death for the power
that he displayed
the ability to manipulate the mind of
doctor doom into leading him to believe
that he'd lived
years and years decades of his life when
in reality it had lasted nothing more
than five seconds was a huge display of
telepathic power especially when you're
talking about using it on someone
as powerful as doctor doom because even
in his base form
while he's not necessarily a universe
level threat he is absurdly powerful
right he's absurdly capable when you add
that to his intelligence the fact that
he
and valeria and reed richards kind of
jockey back and forth for the number one
spot as the most intelligent person in
the marvel universe he usually knows how
to get around people who were using
telepathic attacks on him
so the fact that he couldn't really
speaks volumes to the power that the
marquee of death has
when you add when you add in the idea
that he was just hopping from one
universe to the next wiping out whole
universes with a wave of his hand when
you look at what
is in effect kind of his alternate
reality counterpart but the basis behind
klein winchum still stays the same in
the sense that like he just grabbed
superheroes from an alternate universe
and just brought him into his own in the
in the real world
when you look at the kind of things that
this guy's pulled off and how fast he
was able to do them and how effortless
they seemed i think the number 10 spot
is a respectable place to put him
right he's hugely powerful it's one of
these things and that's why we're kind
of chalking this up to the new
you know marvel cosmic hierarchy because
when we did the original video he didn't
exist
or at least i wouldn't i wouldn't say he
didn't exist i didn't know about him
right but knowing about him and adding
them in
really changes the dynamic of this list
because following that we go into two
characters that are basically classic
characters right we go into the
pre-retcon molecule man and the
pre-retcon beyonder now
technically they're two separate things
right we have a molecule man at number
nine
and beyond her at number eight the
reason why i put molecule man at number
nine is because
in the original secret wars 2 story it
was established that he was slightly
weaker than the beyonder the difference
between their powers was by all
standards of measurement
negligible at least as far as the
average joe was concerned but these guys
were hugely powerful
right at the time that secret wars 2 was
written and the time that it was created
these guys were second to the one above
all right they were beyond the living
tribunal they were beyond pretty much
everybody that was out there and now
other characters have been introduced or
played more prominent roles or
i'm someone just becoming aware of them
this simply weren't on this list before
and so because of that you know
these guys this is a respectable role
something to understand is that there
really was no limit to what these guys
could do
or at the peak of their power these guys
were walking talking cosmic cubes and
one thing to understand is that there
really is no differentiation between
like a cosmic cube and an infinity
gauntlet right i mean i guess maybe
there is insofar as
you know how their powers or how their
abilities originate but they can both
defy the laws of physics right i mean
that's entirely possible and so when you
take that
and you apply to guys like the molecule
man and you apply to guys like beyonder
one they're already multiversal threats
right when the two of them fought at the
end of secret wars two their battle took
place in the multiverse and they were
sending shockwaves throughout the
multiverse right these guys
can turn anything to into anything else
and in fact it was well established in
that story
that they again they were above the
living tribunal and so when you're
talking about classic characters with
that caliber of power where essentially
nothing is beyond their abilities to to
do it's insane right i mean even the
beyond himself actually killed death
right he killed death in the universe
and then resurrected her right it was
just kind of one of those things that
was done on a whim
to display the level of power this guy
had i would say and i continue to say
that in terms of seeing like
displays of abilities the beyonder did
more than the molecule man did in terms
of like grandiose displays of power but
it was also established in that story
that molecule man was
by all standards of measurement equal to
him in power and so he's really more
just kind of like a side along character
that is equal to the beyond right he's
kind of
brought along to you know to the role of
an equal by virtue of the circumstances
as opposed to like displays of abilities
we've seen molecule man do some cool
stuff
but i don't really think we've seen him
do things on the same level that the
beyonder did
in marvel comics but following that by
following molecule man and beyonder we
go into what's probably one of the
coolest characters here
um and a lot of people are gonna argue
with me about this they're actually
gonna see this character being put in
the wrong location
i think it's the right location here
we're picking up with protege now
protege is a kid that i would under
normal circumstances you guys are 100
right under normal circumstances i would
put him second to the fulcrum and the
one above all right i mean the guy was
was absurdly powerful in fact
in marvel comics at the time when he
reached full power it was basically said
that he was he was equal to the one
above all
and power now technically that's not
really true and there's a little bit of
a caveat that comes along when you bring
in the one above all but
he was able to overtake the living
tribunal quite readily uh but the nature
of protege's powers is that he has the
power to duplicate the abilities of
anybody he sees
and there's no limit to the powers he
can copy right so that's why it started
out with him copying the powers of
superheroes and and various villains
that he saw around him when he was
created by the universal church of truth
and then you saw him uh kind of
expanding outward and then copying the
abilities of cosmic entities
and just rapidly rising among the ranks
and just taking out everyone he saw to
the point that uh you actually saw him
encounter the living tribunal and there
was nothing the living tribunal could do
to stop him well there was but we'll
talk about that here and here in a
minute or probably in the next video
by all standards of measurement protege
has no limit to the power he possesses
now
in terms of being equal to the one above
all it doesn't really work that way and
the reason why is because the one above
all is basically a mcguffin right the
way it works in marvel is nobody can be
equal to the one above all because one
above all
equates to like the writers and the
editors and stuff like that or depending
on how you want to look at it equates to
jack kirby it's been interpreted
different ways in marvel comics
the important thing here is that if
protege ever encountered the one above
all the one above all would just shut
his powers off right or just wipe him
from existence and protege wouldn't be
able to bring himself back
there's any number of things i mean
technically within the confines of how
protege's powers work
it wouldn't really make sense right like
how can an entity destroy
an undestroyable entity right how does
that work right unstoppable object
meeting an immovable force
is basically what that would be but
marvel would just kind of chalk it up
and just say yup done because nobody
surpasses the one above all and that's
essentially it
again you know it's one of those things
you just kind of have to roll with in
comics there's really not an absolute
and hard and fast rule here when it
comes to that you just kind of take it
and just go with it and that's basically
it but the last person on our list here
in this video right the last person in
this video
that i'm talking up here is somebody
that i think a lot of people sleep on in
marvel comics right a lot of people
don't really
realize how powerful this guy is not
just on a universal level
but on a multiversal level the last
person on our list in this video here
is oblivion now oblivion is wildly
powerful
in comics right more so because of what
he represents as opposed to what he can
do i mean he can do a lot of things but
oblivion basically represents
nothingness
right like the absence of existence is
essentially what oblivion is and so it's
well established in his early issues or
really when he kind of first starts
popping up in marvel comics that he was
there before the multiverse existed and
he'll be there after it's gone
in effect he will outlive everything
that's out there right and if you're a
cosmic entity that's designed to
represent
non-existence then it makes sense that
you cannot actually be destroyed right
you cannot actually be
be removed from the equation now i know
that flies in the face of conventional
wisdom especially when you look at
somebody like mistress death who
represents the concept of death yet has
died herself i know it's it's it seems
to kind of fly in the face of that and
it looks like it shouldn't make any
sense but for oblivion it does
right and it's one of these things where
oblivion will just always kind of exist
and marvel plays it fast and loose in
previous years marvel's established that
mistress death is an aspect of oblivion
and they've also played it that oblivion
is an aspect of mistress death so it's
kind of gone back and forth but the
overall gist here is that when
everything out there comes to an end
right when it's all basically dead when
the multiverse collapses and then is
eventually reborn by whatever manner and
whatever means that happens to be
oblivion will remain some people argue
he's equal to the one above all in power
i don't necessarily think so i think in
terms of of
symbolism though the kind of position he
plays and the fact that he is sort of
everlasting then sure i think he's equal
to the one above all in that capacity
but with regards to the power he has no
he's not equal to the one above all
in that way but oblivion is far beyond
pretty much almost
pretty much everybody else on this list
now again this also kind of brings in
the notion of protege right could
protege
duplicate the powers of oblivion and
probably uh but just for the sake of
simplicity you know i kind of kept
protege a little bit below oblivion
because there's nothing to indicate that
protege could survive the collapse of
the multiverse unless he'd copy the
powers of like the living tribunal and
even then because a living tribunal is a
representative of the multiverse itself
if the multiverse dies the living
tribunal dies with it
right because it's you know it's it's
it's like destroying a house and
there wouldn't be anything there right
you know the living tribunal is the
answer to the question what if the house
could get up and walk around
something you know one or two steps
above multiversal eternity then when the
multiverse dies the living tribunal dies
as well
and then when the multiverse is
recreated the living tribunal comes back
right and we saw that kind of play out
indirectly
in the jim starlin infinity stories when
uh the living tribunal was killed by the
beyonders and then when the multiverse
was recreated by reed richards that adam
warlock from an alternate reality became
the new living tribunal we saw that
essentially play out
in that way not necessarily a one-to-one
comparison of what we're talking about
here but you know something i can to it
right as close as we get but oblivion
nonetheless i think is probably one of
the single most powerful beings within
the top
six of the marvel cosmic hierarchy on a
multiversal scale it's insane how
powerful he is
he doesn't quite get his respect it's
it's it's sort of nuts when you look at
it but from with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
uh in the next video that we do it'll be
the top five most powerful characters
throughout the entirety of the marvel
multiverse but if you guys are new here
to comments explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anymore